Traductor: Sonia Escudero Sánchez
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
Los anales del rey del
Antiguo Egipto Tutmosis III
describieron un maravilloso
pájaro extranjero que
"daba a luz diariamente".
Los zoroastrianos
los consideraban espíritus
cuyos gritos hablaban
sobre la lucha cósmica
entre la oscuridad y la luz.
Los romanos los llevaron en sus
campañas militares
para predecir el éxito de futuras batallas
Y hoy, este pájaro
aún ocupa una importante,
aunque mucho menos honorable posición:
en nuestros platos.
El pollo moderno desciende
principalmente del gallo bankiva,
y parcialmente de otras tres especies
estrechamente relacionadas
todas nativas de India
y el sudeste de Asia.
El bambú de la región produce
enormes cantidades de fruta
solo una vez cada pocas décadas.
La habilidad de la gallina bankiva
para poner huevos a diario
pudo haber evolucionado para
sacar partido a estos raros festines,
incrementando su población cuando
la fruta era abundante.
Era algo que los humanos podían explotar
sobre una base consistente,
y la débil capacidad de volar de las aves
y su limitada necesidad
de espacio las hizo
fáciles de capturar y almacenar.
Los primeros pollos domesticados,
datan al menos de hace 7000 años,
cuando no fueron criados como comida,
sino para algo considerado
menos sabroso hoy en día.
La agresividad de los machos reproductores
armados con espuelas
naturales en sus patas
hizo de las peleas de gallos
un entretenimiento popular.
Para el segundo milenio a. C.,
los pollos se habían extendido
desde el valle del Indo a China
y el Medio Oriente para pertenecer
a colecciones reales
y ser usados en rituales religiosos.
Pero fue en Egipto
donde comenzó el siguiente capítulo
de la historia de estos pájaros.
Cuando una gallina incuba huevos
de forma natural,
dejará de ponerlos,
y se sentará en una nidada de
entre 6 o más huevos por 21 días.
Para en la mitad del primer milenio a. C.
los egipcios habían aprendido
a incubar artificialmente los huevos
colocándolos en canastas
sobre cenizas calientes.
Eso permitió a las gallinas
continuar poniendo huevos diariamente,
y lo que había sido una delicia real
o una ofrenda religiosa
se convirtió en una comida común.
Casi al mismo tiempo que
los egipcios incubaban huevos,
los mercaderes fenicios introdujeron
los pollos en Europa,
donde rápidamente
se convirtieron en parte esencial
del ganado europeo.
Sin embargo, durante mucho tiempo,
el estatus venerado del pollo
continuó existiendo
junto con su estatus culinario.
Los antiguos griegos
usaban gallos de pelea
como ejemplos inspiradores
para los soldados jóvenes.
Los romanos consultaban
a los pollos como oráculos.
Todavía en el siglo VII,
el pollo fue considerado
un símbolo para el cristianismo.
Durante los siguientes siglos,
los pollos acompañaron a los humanos,
difundiéndose por el mundo
a través del comercio,
conquistas,
y colonización.
Después de las guerras del opio
las razas chinas fueron
llevadas a Inglaterra
y las cruzaron con pollos locales.
Esto dio lugar a un fenómeno llamado
"Fiebre de la gallina"
o "The Fancy",
en la que agricultores de toda Europa
se esfuerzan en criar nuevas variedades
con combinaciones de rasgos particulares.
Esta tendencia llamó también la atención
de un tal Charles Darwin, que se preguntó
si un proceso de reproducción selectiva
ocurrió en la naturaleza.
Darwin observaría cientos de pollos
mientras finalizaba su histórico trabajo
introduciendo la Teoría de la evolución.
Pero la mayor contribución
del pollo a la ciencia
aún estaba por llegar.
A principios del siglo XX,
un trío de científicos británicos
llevó a cabo extensos cruces de pollos,
realizados sobre el trabajo de
Gregor Mendel sobre la herencia genética.
Con su alta diversidad genética,
muchos rasgos distintos,
y solo 7 meses entre generaciones,
los pollos eran los sujetos perfectos.
Este trabajo resultó en
el famoso Cuadro de Punnett,
usado para mostrar
los genotipos que resultarían
de la reproducción
de un par determinado dado.
Desde entonces,
numerosas iniciativas de cría
hizo a los pollos
más grandes y carnosos,
y les permitió poner más huevos que nunca.
Mientras tanto,
la producción de pollos ha cambiado
a un modelo industrial, como una fábrica,
con aves criadas en espacios
no más grandes que una hoja de papel.
Y si bien ha habido un cambio
a la avicultura en libertad
debido a los derechos animales
y preocupaciones ambientales
la mayoría de los más de
22 mil millones de pollos hoy en día
son de cría industrial.
Desde gladiadores
a regalos para los dioses,
a compañeros de viaje
y sujetos de investigación,
los pollos han tenido muchos papeles
a lo largo de los siglos.
Y a pesar de que no hayan llegado
antes del proverbial huevo
la fascinante historia de los pollos
nos dice mucho de la nuestra.